ah yes the first day Peoria it was the
first day this year where I just [ __ ]
walked outside uh I I I I I I walked
outside the day after we got there we
got there the day before then the day of
the show I walked outside and breathed
in that crisp air and just beautiful
wind of just a nice nice nice enough day
a little bit overcast partly cloudy it
was partly cloudy in Peoria and it just
felt [ __ ] so nice dude
and what does it feel like when we feel
that first [ __ ] cold breeze of the
Fall what does it feel like
why does it feel nostalgic
I said it to my wife
my beautiful angel wife hey why does it
feel nostalgic when the cold comes does
it feel nostalgic for you and she goes
like this yeah why and I said why is
that she said probably because we both
grew up on the east coast and I said
yeah but it's just because we used to
feel this and now we don't anymore in
Los Angeles
and she was like yeah I like you know I
like to call it boss Angeles but I said
Los Angeles and she was like yeah and I
was like maybe you're right I don't know
but I [ __ ] am brought back to when I
was a child and it feels nice because I
had a good childhood but also am I
blocking out bad things that happened
who knew
because it also there's a tinge of
sadness what's that all about huh hey
what's up sadness under happiness
what's going on what's going on I'm
happy but also what's going on tinja
sadness
what's going on sad
hey I'm right here just to let you know
oh hey what's up sadness okay well I
guess I'm happy
that first Breeze that first Cool Breeze
of the Fall just
and you're just walking on sunshine oh
and then that first Breeze just under
your shirt
and then
what's up sadness Gunk just right here
what's that all about
thanks for thanks for visiting me in
Peoria
Rockford it was there too then I got
home in La first cold day
sadness is there to stay yes nice we
talk about seasonal depression in in
life and that's a real thing are we all
just [ __ ] or is it a real thing what
does it matter if I feel it if it's
psychosomatic attic insane what does it
matter if I feel it
God family
attic insane dude
you know
act insane act insane
um
Every Time I Think of Peoria I think of
The Little Shop of Horrors where they go
and Peoria
New York
dude and if you can make it in [ __ ]
Peoria they say that you can make it
you're in you made it anywhere so [ __ ]
yeah dude made it made it again dude
[ __ ] yeah I made it dude
I can make it in Peoria and New York we
got the New York tickets on sale
February 18th we got New York Beacon
Theater New York playing a Beacon
Theater February 18th I've been playing
in Chicago we go to Chicago
so
um anyway the sadness is right there
right behind the happiness and uh and we
all trudge through my babies we all
trudge through don't we people come up
to me after shows I do the meet and
greet and they'd say yeah I've been
through a really hard time and your
stuff lifts me up and dude you know what
I'll be Josh Groban to you [ __ ]
okay I will raise you up man I used to
shy to that and be like oh please not
enough but please enough enough enough
you don't need to be all you know
sentimental and I feel bad and oh that's
nothing and yeah you know you dude I'm
happy to be here for you how about that
I am happy to be here for you
if you're listening to this podcast and
you had a shitty day and you were
looking forward to this podcast to turn
it on so you could get some [ __ ]
yucks I am happy to be here for you
because I know you feel the [ __ ]
sadness behind the happiness too
sometimes and I am happy to be here for
you whether you're in purion
[Music]
work but he's [ __ ] nice with it dude
he's absolutely nice with it he can sing
and at a insane dude
he's absolutely nice with it
so come see me that don't push me tour
and uh God damn we had a good time in
Peoria for some reason Adam Ray came
with me a hilarious comedian Mike La
Noche came with me a hilarious comedian
we just had a ball dude [ __ ] Adam
Ray's got this Dr Phil impression that
makes me [ __ ] laugh dude
go to go check it out on YouTube or
something probably but
um yeah dude it was really nice the cold
breezes here and I guess I'm happy dude
you know it's like it's really kind of
annoying to me here comes my hater [ __ ]
dude and I don't mean to be a hater and
sometimes I'm not a a hater I'm just
speaking facts right fax
um
I don't like when people you know it's
like the whole there it's that time
again where the breeze all that [ __ ]
chick a white chick especially needs a
white chick with like a vest like a
brown vest and a white sweater under it
all she all she needs is that [ __ ]
that first Breeze and she goes get the
brown vest get it get it get it get it
get it get the [ __ ] the yarned up
sweater where that goes over my you know
how much do [ __ ] chicks love just
having it so they can't even barely they
use they scoop up the [ __ ] ends of
the uh sleeves and they're just like
this you know what I mean oh did you
feel that that's what the collective ooh
did you feel that on the first
under the shirt get the vest oh did you
feel that
it just moves from east to west as as
the because you know it gets warmer and
oh did you feel did you would you feel
that would you feel it did you feel did
you feel there would you feel that by
the end in San Diego
dude it's just it sweeps up off the
Atlantic in Atlantic City
Tennessee
[ __ ] Nebraska what are the [ __ ] in
the middle there who knows
and then [ __ ] all the way to San
Diego did you feel that yeah
get the get the Brown Band Brown get the
brown get up around a couple kids get
brown get the brown look it's like a
horror movie what is this
oh
from the makers
of oh did you feel that comes Brown vest
a Netflix movie with you know even
though it's about white chicks we also
have a bunch of other [ __ ] colors in
it too and you won't be able to tell
anyone's sexuality Netflix
oh did you feel that
um
so yeah um I don't even really honestly
know what I was talking about I just
kind of lost track then it's all good
because that's what we do we [ __ ] fly
by the seat of our pants and that's what
we do in this podcast and it's the only
podcast that'll [ __ ] do it to you
it's the only podcast that'll do it to
you I see other [ __ ] have
notepads your boy don't have any
notepads man I know [ __ ] they
seem to be [ __ ] stream of
Consciousness but let me tell you
something dude I'm the stream of
conscious dude okay I haven't looked at
a note yet dude
all I did was [ __ ] and I'm not that's
not a brag or a flex I'm just saying
dude I respect you enough to be truly me
crazy crazy
crazy crazy
you're crazy
[Music]